اعلنت الحكومه البولنديه مقتل شخصين جرا
سقوط صاروخين روسيين في بولندا
وهذه صور
لاثار سقوط الصاروخين الروسيين على بلده
بارزيدوز ديمو مقاطعه لوبيسكي قرب الحدود
الاوكرانيه
بصاروخين طائشين
الرئاسه البولنديه ذاكره الرئيس البولنديه
دوده يجري مكالمه عاجله في هذه الاثناء مع
نظيره الامريكي بشان التطورات الاخيره
باسم الرئاسه البولنديه تنظر في امكانيه
تفعيل الماده الرابعه من ميثاقوته التي
تنص على حق العضو في الحلفي دعوه دول
الحلف للتشاور واضاف المسؤول البولندي ان
الحكومه قررت رفع درجه جاهزيه الوحدات
العسكريه
الرئيس الاوكراني في الاردن روسيا
باستهداف الاراضي البولنديه من جهه هكذا
تيمو في
نوفا مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني في مقابله
مع الجزيره ان بلاده ستكشف عن الادله التي
تثبت ان الصواريخ التي سقطت على بولندا
كانت روسيا
الادله راينا هذا الامر في بدايه الحرب
ورايناه مؤخرا في مساله رفع الاعلام الخطا
وفي كل مقابله مع وسائل الاعلام كان هناك
انكار من روسيا والقاء لللوم على اوكرانيا
وبعد ذلك يثبت انهم على خطا هناك ادله
ستتكشف ربما خلال يوم او يومين ستثبت ان
تلك الصواريخ كانت روسيه
وقد نفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صح تمام
روسيه في منطقه
برزيدوز قرب الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه
وتمت الوزاره وسائل الاعلام البولنديه
بالقيام باستفزازات متعمده لتصعيد الموقف
واضافه اي اسلحه روسيه لضرب اهداف قرب
الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه
واكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان صور الحصان
الذي صارت وسائل الاعلام البولنديه لنشرها
في منطقه
لا علاقه لها باي اسلحه روسيه